but you wouldn't change anything like
maybe like give her a big fat ass well
that's yeah you were saying that earlier
yeah big old ass what position would she
permanently be in
all fours
[Laughter]
[Music]
everybody take a look at this
and tell me if there's anything like uh
unique about it nice little Indian
couple
how come the ladies keeps looking in the
wrong direction of the camera I know
yeah they look Frozen the dude is
looking at the camera and both of them
she's a doll oh my God
real she's not real they're both
taxidermy
I know I know the Taxidermy couple when
I see one who's the one that got them
for the kids they want to hang out with
their pants
I believe in eating cold no the guy is
real the mom is I don't know dude I
don't know man that's the funniest no
they're both Texas yeah that's the twist
I know Tim's dad want to be taxidermied
so like he's at the door okay I can give
him a high five it's not that crazy so
what this is is a grieving Indian
husband paid 2 500 for a life-size
silicone copy of his dead wife wow
that's pretty tight you like that [__]
up dude
got her at like her prime
when would a pride be what age is it
when they first met bro like what if she
was like 14. when's Hannah's friend
when's Hannah's day I'll let Santa do
when I first met her like a year ago
you think you think she lost some value
dude no I think she's getting hotter now
oh Oh that's oh look at you cleaning up
your mess
hey she watches the videos not like your
girl I know I know that's why you got to
clean up don't bring my girls into this
my girls
[Laughter]
you guys don't have to clean up anything
they don't watch the videos that's why
we can give our greatest Christmas
wishes and we know they won't be
answered I didn't get no [__] on
Christmas dude that's what she wanted a
water filter that's what I wanted when
was your problem a year ago well she's
getting hotter now
hey I'm romantic bro you're pandering
[__] that's what you are what a Twist
I'm trying to get laid
so would you do that would you have a
copy made of Anna like if she you know
disappeared yeah but I'll [__] I'd do
way better yeah like one year ago better
you mean you do way better I think we
know what he means I change all the [__]
that I've been wanting to change on her
that's right
like a [__] fossil right okay like
80s or something yeah 80s yeah I would
preserve the the Hannah today
not the geriatric counter of tomorrow
and then I'll I'll look like a I'll look
more like a huge hat I'm an old [__]
hamster
probably with the long hair like oh yeah
yeah yeah because Japanese people when
they turn into grandpas they either look
like a monkey or a hamster I'll probably
that's the only choices yeah
I probably will I think I'm more of a
hamster than a monkey but then uh yeah
that'll be would you interact with the
dog by that time I think technology is
going to be so [__] good yeah that I
can like AI her yeah oh no we're working
on silicone dummies
that's that's what this context is no Ai
No technology is good just 2500 silicone
dummy that's a good deal keeper young
and hot yeah it's cheaper than that
guy's dog costume that's what I'm saying
bro that dog costume was like it was
cool but it was also a rip-off like all
you could do is roll around in it yeah
that seems like a good deal so he
actually sits the uh the the silicone
wife down on her favorite spot of couch
brushes her hair what a simp ass [__]
that's what the
they already you make fun of them and
this video is monetized do you think
this is a healthy way to grieve
nothing or is he even grieving is he
even grieving or is he just having a
good time these cops coping maybe yeah
oh my God I just read something that'll
make us all change our opinions he beats
that silicone dummy up at night he's
gonna get taxidermied okay so
um
he beats her up
it's a punching bag in terms of how she
died because like you know oh [__] um I
think one of his like reasons for
wanting to do this is because he went
through so much grief because she died
alone in the hospital while he was not
allowed to go because of covid oh
[Music]
yeah but like she's more beautiful now
[Laughter]
come on cleaning up it's real dirty out
here
damn yo this changes everything dude she
was taken from him that really does yeah
see ouch that's not fair to me no I look
like a bad guy it's not fair to me you
do look like such a bad guy the rest of
us are judging you because of how bad
you look all of us are definitely fine
all of us are fine all of us are fine
okay
all right I'll keep her as a old ass
[__] I I think that's the best because
of the covet stuff dude you're winning
us over
I'll keep her as old as [__] that makes
more sense dude but you wouldn't change
anything like maybe like give her a big
fat ass well that's yeah you're saying
that earlier yeah big old ass what
position would she permanently be in
all fours
that was a little awful that was an
underhanded lob dude all fours nice
nice Sports he teed it up for him no he
put it up on the t-ball I didn't think
you were gonna freaking get a part two
you know I'm a slam dunker baby I gotta
take the bait I love a lot of you guys
both said part two and slam dunker yeah
we're volleyball players
we get Sports
you know what sucks though like there's
so many people that went through that
during lockdown like yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah it just people passed no like
proper funeral none of that no hospital
visit yeah but it saved lives
that's what matters do you think there's
anything guys like this [__] was a
pandemic I think he has like
conspiracies against I think he's more
mad about all that than anybody could
possibly I would [__] be if I was him
dude I would like yo [__] this this is
everybody who had loved ones in the
hospital couldn't see him it's probably
pissed yeah and now everyone's like out
like it never happened I know a lot of
Amnesia going around yeah
depending on the country I guess that's
true hey dude Sweden came out of that
thing like pretty sick Florida never
even they just opened up right Florida
didn't go in Africa
nobody died of covert in Africa crazy
really zero it was like what was it five
percent that's because they're healthy
dude exactly it's crazy it's crazy how
much that had to do with it look how
good this is though like look at this
work 2500 seems like super cheap that's
a good deal that's really good it's kind
of a scary facial expression
but what if that's how she looks Anthony
no like to hold forever
Ryan
[Laughter]
let's say my name are you sure that's
the silicone version that does look real
it looks so real dude you know what I
would do to add to this though if if I
if I was the silicone company here we go
hands like this
that's good no what if it's this same
company that makes sex dolls because it
makes sense just as a business no you
could put stuff you put flowers in your
hands like a koozie you're such a
sweetheart the company that made this
one I think they're like professional
sculptors that's wonderful I don't think
they make sex sculptures no so I'll I'll
say they're missing out on a huge shot
of the business then you know the
technology missing on Revenue you know
the technology that that they use for
heating blankets I put that in their
bodies
so their bodies are warm so you can hug
them
and he's like he's like dude volume
three we need you know the companies
that make um vaginas moist
exactly we're gonna put that in there we
also gotta plug her in though oh you
know uh battery packs
just like an iPhone
yeah yeah plug and unplug she has a USB
port yeah oh you know be dope like a
massage chair now on her arms it does
the massages you yeah so she warms up
close the fingers
is there any firmware for that see
that's why sex doll and this like
closure doll it's a slippery slope
closure
yeah it should be dude sex dolls are
wild it is really yeah so it waits wait
till they get good dude I think if I
were to say if I was a single male and I
wouldn't get a sex doll I would probably
never leave my house dude it only weighs
66 pounds
if you had a sex doll that looked
exactly like a real woman yeah and you
could design her to your own
specifications yeah I'm never leaving
the world will grind to a [__] world
no wonder so many males are [__] not
working the word the world will there'll
be no Trucking
yeah but they're see that's why no wood
gets cut
that heated blanket technology has to be
used to because all of them are probably
really cold have you touched the [__]
chicken cutlet fake boob thing that the
girls use
look like it looks like a chicken breast
they put that [__] oh okay
I know what you mean now yeah I thought
you meant literal like but they do kind
of look like chicken cutlet though yeah
it looks like a chicken breast yeah and
it's cold
it's not cold when they're wearing it
because then their pity Heats it up it's
cold when they're dead right Joe
[Music]
foreign